et ce matin nous inviter sur les
journalistes antoine isambart qui est
sur ce plateau et franck renaud qui va
nous rejoindre dans un instant merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ensemble vous
venez de signer ce livre trahison à la
dgse révélations sur le vrai bureau des
légendes pour ceux qui qui connaissent
la série télé ça va leur dire quelque
chose tu as récit passionnant aux
éditions stock en fait vous intéresser à
ces agents des renseignements français
qui sont devenus ce qu'on appelle des
taupes des agents doubles des gens des
agents parfois triple qui en gros
informe des services de renseignement
étrangers en particulier la chine parce
que le point de départ de ce livre c'est
la condamnation en juillet 2022 ancien
agent de la dgse à des peines de prison
lourdes très lourdes pour trahison au
profit de la chine on va beaucoup parler
de ses services chinois ensemble de
leurs méthodes et puis votre co auteurs
venus rejoindre dans un instant mais
d'abord antoine isambart avec
l'actualité je voudrais qu'on parle un
peu de de la russie parce que et de ces
tensions avec l'ukraine vous parlez des
services secrets russes dans ce livre de
la façon dont ils essaient de détourner
les agents européens est-ce qu'ils sont
encore capables ici de retourner des
agents de la dgse ils ont quelques fans
des fois quand même auprès de l'armée
française août certains de certains
agents les russes oui ont retourné des
gens de la dg si on n'a pas eu de cas en
tout cas connus et que nous a rapporté
mais eu un cas d'un radiothon colonel en
poste à l'otan un français qui a été mis
en examen
pour trahison profit de la russie à
l'été 2020 et donc effectivement la
russie aujourd'hui est considéré comme
étant un des pays les plus agressifs et
ayant une agressivité supérieure à ce
qu'elle était finalement au niveau de la
guerre froide donc que ce soit le svr
qui est le sel de renseignement
extérieur russe le fsb qu'il s'agisse de
renseignements intérieurs mais qui
mènent des opérations également à
l'étranger j'ai réussi nous loger à ruud
a vu un peu les pieds nickelés aussi à
l'étranger donc il ya une agressivité
finalement aujourd'hui extrêmement forte
et voilà poutine qui était un ancien
espion ancien patron du fsb sait
exactement comment ça se passait et on
joue aisément votre livre évoque donc
les renseignements us mais aussi chinois
c'est le résultat 2 en enquête une
soixantaine de source le point de départ
c'est donc cette condamnation d'henry et
de pierre à marie donc deux ex agents de
la dgse qui ont travaillé en sous main
pour les services chinois pendant plus
de dix ans près de 15 ans même pour l'un
à la révélation de la faire
on sait peu de chose au début cette
affaire a été rendu public mais on a su
très peu de choses à ce que vous pouvez
c'est pas facile me résumer brièvement
cette histoire oui en fait il ya au
départ il ya mon co auteur franck renaud
fait un bouquin en 2010 dans lequel il
évoque en quelques lignes le fait
qu'henri qui était le chef de pause
entre l'équivalent de l'ambassadeur de
la dgse en chine en 98 a eu une aventure
avec une chinoise et traductrice de
l'ambassadeur voilà et s'est fait
débarquer donc quatre lignes le l'espion
henry en question on voit de nombreux
mails assez agressif à franck il se
passe pas grand chose finalement
et donc la sphère ressort finalement 2
pour le grand public avec tmc l'émission
de fin sur tmc l'émission quotidien qui
en 2018 finalement de l'information de
l'arrestation de ces deux agents après
il quelques articles mais mais mais pas
grand chose et c'est vrai que nous on a
eu envie
puisque franck connaissait l'un des deux
mois à travers un précédent ouvrage
avait également pu approcher des gens
qui avaient connu cette affaire-là on a
eu envie de creuser notamment à partir
de la condamnation donc en en juillet
2020 35 ans après le sabotage du rainbow
warrior au jour pour jour
ses agents et à koné à 8 et 12 ans qu'on
est là on a remonté un peu le fil on a
on a interrogé pas mal d'anciens de la
maison
voilà des espions des diplomates et on a
pu voilà pénétrer un petit peu sur le
comment la chine finalement s'est
attaqué à la dgse et surtout finalement
qui est peut-être le plus important
c'est comment les espions français sont
avant tout des hommes et leurs failles
finalement sont utilisés par les
services adverses c'est profondément ce
qui ressort de ce livre parce que là on
parle d'hommes aguerris qui sont les
services de renseignement depuis très
longtemps qui connaissent les pièges
mais on joue sur leur frustration de ne
pas être promus de ne pas avoir les
postes qu'ils veulent ou ne pas avoir
assez d'argent il ya les pouces d'un 2
qui dit attendez on habite à versailles
en avait un rang à tenir on n'était pas
assez payés il fallait bien trouver
l'argent quelque part c'est la femme de
pierre-marie d'huile et l'agent français
qui a livré donc le plus de documents
sensibles au régime chinois notamment
des documents classifiés venue des
archives où l'avait été mis au placard
il touche et 20000 euros à chaque voyage
on lui payer des vacances à l'île
maurice au sri lanka et rencontrer son
agent de liaison chinois et repartez
avec une valise en cash vingt mille
euros il y en aurait eu une dizaine ils
auraient encaissé près de près de 200000
euros pendant des années comment
expliquer que la boîte la dgse derrière
vue est évidemment une un manquement et
une faille côté des gse c'est à dire que
les premiers signaux
d'henry en fait henri là il a une
relation avec l'interprète chinoise il
est débarqué dans la foulée mis à la
retraite
et après la dgse va quand même tenter de
garder un peu un oeil sur lui en chine
en demandant de temps en temps à ses
agents de savoir où henry et ce qu'il
fait sauf que derrière je dirais qu'il
ya eu une remontée de l'information qui
a pu être efficaces mais c'est plutôt le
traitement on va dire côté de la
direction et notamment de la direction
du renseignement qui a pu à l'époque
causer problème parce qu'effectivement
il aurait peut-être fallu que henry sera
encore plus suivis pour éviter sa pierre
marie cessé dans un second temps donc
c'est en 2006 véritablement alors
qu'henri lui collaborent ddd 98 donc
pierre-marie finalement et est recruté
par henri en quelque sorte un mari et un
agent actif c'est un peu le graal pour
tout service de renseignements c'est
d'arriver à recruter quelqu'un qui est
dans un service adverse et qui actif
donc les chinois arrivent à le faire et
pierre-marie effectivement va mener
plusieurs voyages il va y avoir des
dépôts d'argent dans la banque familiale
et ça va être repérées que tardivement
puisque c'est en 2015 finalement que les
premières remontées d'information
arrivent il sait pas par les services de
renseignement ce qui est incroyable
c'est que c'est un espion la dgse qui se
fait attraper parce que les mallette de
cash de 20 mille euros qui ramène à
chaque fois son épouse fait la bêtise de
les encaisser sur le compte courant du
couple une bêtise que comme il y en a
beaucoup cet aspect humain on va en
parler d'ailleurs avec votre co auteur
franck renaud qui nous a rejoints en
direct de nantes bonjour franck bonjour
l'humain compte énormément dans ses
affaires il ya des maîtresses il ya des
amants on joue sur le ressenti sur
l'abandon sur le sentiment d'exclusion
de certains agents il ya donc des
épouses qui déposent des pots-de-vin en
liquide sur des comptes bancaires or on
utilise les faiblesses personnelles par
exemple il ya un agent de la dgse qui se
retrouvent en poste en ex-yougoslavie et
sa fille tombe enceinte d'un agent
yougoslave on le fait chanter en filmant
en secret l'avortement fait on se rend
compte qu'à chaque fois
le meilleur moyen de pénétrer un service
de renseignements c'est l'huma est le
meilleur moyen de faire ton un espion
c'est au sigma y compris pour des agents
aguerris oui bien sûr dont on parle
aujourd'hui beaucoup du cyber et du
renseignement que l'on peut obtenir sur
le cyber qui est capital a bien entendu
mais bien évidemment l'une l'humain et
que ce soit avec les leviers
traditionnels que sont l'argent légaux
la compromission et le sexe l'humain
jouent un rôle toujours essentiel dans
ces affaires de de retournement d'agents
et la dgse notre service de
renseignement extérieur en a été victime
entre guillemets avec avec henry et
pierre marie avec cette affaire qui a
quand même duré près de vingt ans
antoine isambart l'ailé des
renseignements vivent toujours dans la
dans la hantise du traître pourquoi est
ce qu'un agent travaille
alors dans le regardant dans le roman
est dans la jeunesse de l'espionnage il
ya le d'acronymes ice en fait qui est un
peu les cinq leviers levier que peuvent
activer les services de renseignement
donc il ya les goya l'argent il ya
l'idéologie à la compromission
traditionnellement c'est que l'idéologie
est plutôt le plus sûr parce que voilà
c'est un engagement personnel très fort
et l'argent est considéré comme un bon
levier mais un levier on va dire un peu
plus dangereux parce qu'un agent peu
corrompu peut toujours se vendre au plus
offrant mais dans le cas de rim et
pierre-marie les les deux véritable
levier ça a été effectivement l'argent
et on va dire légaux avec un
ressentiment assez fort vis-à-vis de la
dgse voilà des agents qui est sliimy
qu'il n'avait pas eu la carrière qu'il
méritait au sein de la boîte oui parce
qu'on se retrouve avec des agents
profondément anti communiste qui vont
les collaborer quand même avec les
services secrets chinois oui c'est ça
qui est très fort c'est surtout vrai
pour portières mari qui était considéré
comme véritablement quelqu'un
d'anti soviétique d'anti communiste qui
avait travaillé dans les années 80-90 au
contre espionnage qui avait justement
traquer des communistes les mouvements
des brigades rouges notamment et donc
voilà et c'est quelqu'un qui finalement
pour des raisons d'argent pour un
déclassement au sein de la boîte va se
vendre et au procès voilà il a notamment
dit que pour lui il n'avait pas eu le
sentiment de trahir la france mais qu'il
avait plutôt trahi la dgse franck renaud
ce qui est surprenant c'est qu'on
apprend dans le livre que les
renseignements français en ont décidé
d'intenter un procès on aurait pu régler
ça en interne à huit clos sans faire de
vagues comme ça se passe souvent avec
les services de renseignement du monde
entier pourquoi avoir voulu intenter une
action en justice était le patron de la
dgse qui avait fait ce soit à l'époque
oui c'était bernard bajolet qui avait
été nommé par françois hollande qui est
un diplomate et selon les informations
qu'on a pu recueillir avec antoine il ya
deux principales raisons la première un
peu d'ordre géopolitique c'était 2-2 de
donner un peu mettre un coup d'arrêt aux
agissements de la république populaire
de chine en france qui qui se
considérait un peu comme en terrain
conquis et et n'hésitez pas à aller nous
at on dit des marchés et cherchait à
recruter des agents alors ça ça a été le
le premier point un signal à pékin et
puis le deuxième point c'était un peu un
signal en interne au sein de la dgse de
dire aux personnels de la dgse qui soit
contractuels ou militaire ou civil leur
dire attention maintenant on joue plus à
en interne derrière des portes closes ça
peut être judiciariser et c'est vrai
c'est avec la sphère rousseau dans les
années 60 c'est la première phase est la
première fois en tout cas qu une double
trahison et jugés en france les basques
au delà de cette affaire chinoise votre
livre retrace aussi un plusieurs
affaires de trahison et d'agents de l'ag
de dg à ceux qui ont été renversés à
propos de la chine
ce qu'on découvre c'est qu'en gros il ya
un vide abyssal quant à la surveillance
de la chine jusque dans les années 70 il
ya deux agents qui parlent le mandarin
au siège de la dgse il faudra beaucoup
de temps pour prendre la mesure de la
menace chinoise employés d'en bas oui il
ya eu c'est vrai un retard alors bon
dans les années 90 la montée en
puissance chinoise a aussi permis
finalement de recruter d'autres agents
mais il ya eu effectivement je dirais
que la chine n'était pas forcément
très stratégique elle est aujourd'hui
beaucoup mais c'est très compliqué
d'avoir du renseignement en chine c'est
très compliqué d'avoir des interprètes
chinois c'est très compliqué comment
réussit d'ailleurs de pour un agent de
faire du renseignement d'évoluer
librement en chinois en russie donc la
plupart des sources recruté par la dgse
en chine ou en russie c'est plutôt à
l'extérieur de ces pays là et
effectivement il ya eu je dirais 1 et
puis également une sorte de tête de
supériorité un peu côté français à
l'époque en dix ans la chine voilà il ya
ils sont peut-être beaucoup ils font du
renseignement mais il nous arrive pas à
la cheville aujourd'hui on voit que ça a
changé à la dgse accordent de
l'importance à la chine mais il ya eu
effectivement il ya une vingtaine
d'années quand même un retard et une
suffisance peut-être de nos services
mais à vis de la chine voilà un retard
qu'on essaie de rattraper aujourd'hui je
suis désolé messieurs on doit faire
malheureusement cours vous le savez
l'actualité très chargée aujourd'hui
avec la la situation en ukraine mais je
ne saurais que trop recommander ce livre
c'est passionnant s'appelle trahison à
la dgse révélations sur le vrai bureau
des légendes c'est publié chez stock
s'est sorti depuis peu et je vous avoue
que c'est mon livre de chevet on y
apprend beaucoup de choses et puis plein
d'anecdotes notamment sur les procédés
des renseignements russes qui ont l'art
de d'investir les bars d'hôtel avec
parfois de charmante espionne merci
beaucoup à tous les 2es et merci à vous